most political issues come down to first
principles our premises the basic lens
through which we view the world
interpretive principles philosophy
theology even things that reasonable
people might disagree over
but sometimes unfortunately these
debates are much dumber
sometimes these political debates hinge
on sheer ignorance over basic facts
that is where the debate stands at the
moment on the biden administration's
raid of president trump's home at
mar-a-lago
when it comes to the mar-a-lago raid
putting aside all of the complex issues
that it raises
many libs don't understand or don't want
to admit that they understand the most
basic relevant fact which is that the
president has the absolute authority to
declassify material
a former president has never been and
very likely can never be convicted of
mishandling classified material
because the president can declassify
whatever material he wants
wherever and whenever he wants to do it
i thought that was common knowledge but
apparently lots of people don't actually
understand it or want to admit it i was
on two tv shows this past weekend one on
c-span the other on fox and i was
shocked genuinely shocked to discover
that the libs that i spoke with
did not seem to know that
so it bears repeating once more for the
people in the bleachers
the president has the absolute right to
declassify
whatever he wants even the most super
duper extra top secret material whatever
he wants to
there are processes for declassifying
material
even so the president is not bound by
those processes the president doesn't
need to check with some middling
bureaucrat at the doj or at any other
agency to declassify information the
middling careerist
might have some authority in some
circumstances to declassify material
but the middling bureaucrat doesn't
outrank the president
the president doesn't need a special
stamp to declassify material the very
moment that the president decides to
declassify material
that material is declassified the very
best argument that the libs can make for
raiding trump over classified material
is that
we just don't know for sure if it's
legit or not because it's unprecedented
that's the best spin that the left-wing
fact-check quote-unquote website
politifact could give it
politifact writes quote we're in
uncharted territory on the issue of
criminality criminally prosecuting a
former president over mishandling
classified documents there is no legal
precedent to look to for guidance it
raises all sorts of constitutional
implications and it is anyone's guess
how it would play out
same goes for the new york times which
admits that quote the classification
system is not really enforced by
criminal law but rather just
bureaucratic punishments demotions the
loss of security clearances that sort of
thing nothing
that could possibly affect a president
on whether presidents have to obey the
usual procedures the new york times
admits quote there is no supreme court
president definitively answering that
question
the times admits that even in the case
of nuclear secrets quote for the
purposes of criminal law there is little
substantive difference
with any other classified material and
finally the new york times can't even
deny
that the president's ability to
declassify
without leaving a written record is
clear as trump claims uh he did he said
that he didn't leave a written record
but he just said it was declassified
that's the way it goes instead the new
york times calls the question
borderline incoherent because if there's
no directive memorializing a decision to
declassify information and conveying it
to the rest of the government
the action would essentially have no
consequence as departments and agencies
would continue to consider that
information classified and so would
continue to restrict access to documents
containing it
but of course the action would and does
have a consequence in one crucial area
it determines whether or not a president
such as donald trump
mishandled classified information
which the president cannot do
because he is the president the only
reason there is any ambiguity to this
question at all
is because no president has ever been
investigated or prosecuted for
mishandling classified information
because the very thought of it is absurd
because the president can declassify
whatever he wants and because that right
comes absolutely from the constitution
and is not established by some
bureaucratic process
he cannot be punished for not following
any particular process and by the way
for anyone out there who for whatever
reason may still remain skeptical
the way that you can know that i am
right about this is that the libs are
already beginning to change their tune
just days after defending the raid on
that basis
they're beginning to see that the
mishandling classified material defense
of the raid is going absolutely nowhere
that's why they're already beginning to
move the goal posts because the raid was
never about classified documents here it
is new york times right here trump
claims he declassified all the documents
even if that's true probably doesn't
matter yeah because it was never about
that it was never about the presidential
records act
it was never about nuclear secrets or
any other serious national security
matter
it's all about getting trump
it's about stopping him from running in
2024. it's a punishment in search of a
crime i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from the color sage
who says i remember watching bugs bunny
and elmer fudd as a kid i'm pretty sure
that the dems are elmer fudd and trump
is bugs and we're just going to keep
living reruns for eternity oh yeah we've
got you dao we've got you now mr widow
trump oh yeah
yeah what's up duck
no i'm sorry that was fouchy listen
what's up doc i got to work it's very
difficult i'm trying to combine a
cartoon with
politicians it's very hard i need i need
a little bit more energy to do it you
know i need my iron pumping through my
blood you know what i need i need good
ranchers right now head on over to
goodranchers.com
knowles regardless of what this
administration defines as a recession
americans are worried because we're in a
recession food and gas prices are higher
than i've ever seen in my lifetime that
is why i am so grateful for my favorite
meat delivery service good ranchers good
ranchers offers a recession proof
subscription model that lets you lock in
the price the day you subscribe so not
only is it recession-proof it's
inflation-proof too it's absolutely a
ridiculous deal i have no idea how these
guys are going to stay in business
because they've got top quality meat
they're giving you ridiculously
affordable prices and you can lock it in
as inflation turns us all into zimbabwe
we're going to have you know
wheelbarrows full of trillion dollar
bills soon but you'll still have great
meat good ranchers is also currently
running a back to school give back
program with the goal of donating 100
000 high quality meals to children in
need to help out i am offering 10 lucky
listeners the chance to win 30 minutes
with me
via zoom on september 30th where you can
ask me anything we're calling it a meet
and greet get it go to
goodranchers.com use code knowles at
checkout you'll get 30 bucks off plus
free shipping you can subscribe to lock
in your price and recession slash
inflation proof your meals for life plus
you'll be automatically entered to win
30 minutes of all access with me
september 30th it's a meet and greet
this offer ends august 31st go to
goodranchers.com knowles use code
knowles at checkout and maybe i'll see
you at the meet and greet
there it is here are the goal posts
moving already
we've got trump we had to raid the home
of biden's chief political rival and the
former president because he had
classified documents
uh yeah but that doesn't matter yeah
okay you're right it doesn't matter but
whatever it's good that they rated him
anyway that's that's what we're getting
right now from the new york times
doesn't matter
who cares if it was declassified moving
on moving on
this should not surprise us the libs
have been doing this since 2016.
i love that comment about bugs bunny
that's what we keep seeing
they've got him now
oh the walls are closing in it's mueller
time
yeah we got trump we got him because he
colluded with the russians yeah we got
him now oh that didn't work okay well he
may have slept with a porn star and
that's really bad for so i don't know
why i mean that's bad that's morally bad
but it we're gonna
get him on that i guess no okay we're
not gonna do that
okay well okay he didn't collude with
the russians i know he colluded with the
ukrainians yeah we're gonna impeach him
for that because he colluded with the
enemy of russia after he colluded with
no okay all right we're not going to get
him on that are we okay well he um huh
he launched an insurrection yeah oh yeah
we got you now trump you dirty no okay
all right got them up okay well now we
go but your you didn't pay some of your
taxes maybe are we do we have you on
that no okay we don't have you on that
uh um
you had client it's just gonna go on
guys it's gonna it's just gonna go on
forever for and i hope that trump
remains bugs and remains one step ahead
of the the elmer fudd democrats i hope i
hope that the dems don't finally get him
by throwing the entire weight of the
liberal establishment
behind them
but
that's all this is this is a prosecution
in search of a crime i think we're on
crime number eight that they've tried to
throw at this guy it's all the
punishment is always the same the
punishment is always you don't get to be
president that's all they really care
about you're disqualified from running
for president you're getting impeached
and thrown out of office you your
campaign gets killed in the cradle
you're that's always the punishment why
because it has nothing to do with any of
the crimes or even non-crimes they're
accusing him of it's all about stopping
him from becoming president they want to
stop him from becoming president
not even because he sends mean tweets
he's off of twitter right now so there's
no fear of the president sending mean
tweets
they want to stop him because he wants
to change our trade regime he wants to
stop illegal immigration he wants to to
take power away from the liberal
globalists who are giving away our
national sovereignty he wants to change
the structure of the political order
that the libs have gotten away with for
the better part of three or four decades
maybe more
that's what this is all about
it's just about
stopping
a conservative from
going in and messing up all of the
liberals
plans that's what this is all about now
we find out the fbi apparently seized
documents
that were covered by attorney-client
privilege and executive privilege the
fbi took documents that were protected
not only by
by the rights of presidents to keep
certain information but even by the
right of any client to keep information
private between him and his lawyer this
is no surprise they're going to break
all the rules they've committed so many
crimes going back to 2016 the the fbi
lawyer lied to a fisa court judge
completely made up evidence so that they
could spy on the trump campaign there is
no law they will not break there is no
law that they will consider too
important that they have to respect it
they're going to use everything they can
to get this guy
and the most frustrating part of it all
is not that the libs are doing this it's
not that our institutions of government
law enforcement are extremely corrupt
the most frustrating part of all as far
as i can tell is when the squish fake
republicans
applaud and go along with it
you know
it just makes me want to take a break
from all the intensity of the news cycle
get into a nice digital community where
we're free of the bots free of the
trolls we get to just share good stuff
that doesn't melt our brains that's why
you gotta check out tuvu right now go to
tuvu.com knowles it is time to take a
stand and stop feeding the big tech
beast that wants to cancel us all and
censor us all and isolate us from one
another on social media you've been
hearing me talk about tuvu which is the
new
subscription-based alternative that
weeds out the bots and the trolls and
the invasive ads and the algorithms that
make big tech such a toxic place tuvu is
the photo sharing community app built on
family values data privacy and freedom
of opinion it's time to move our
communities our families and our
churches to a better place online where
big tech is not pushing its woke agenda
it's vice it's addictive content and
it's damaging
mental health
accessories tuvu is ad-free so they
answer to you the subscriber on twoview
your data will never be sold to
advertisers and data miners instead
touvu sells social media freedom to
those who use it for just 2.99 a month
or 22.99 per year he who pays the piper
calls the tune that right there weeds
out the fakes and the bots and the
trolls are you hesitant to try a new
platform for the next seven days only
tuvu is giving our listeners a free
annual membership when you go to
www.tuvu.com
t-u-v-u dot com slash knowles get all
the details and your free annual
subscription for a limited time only at
twofood.com knowles t-u-v-u dot com
slash knowles or look for the tuvu app
on google play or the app store
the squishes are still defending the fbi
and the doj even after the mar-a-lago
raid this is the this is a great rule of
thumb as to how you can tell a
conservative from a squish are they
defending the fbi are they defending the
doj
even after
six seven years of this but especially
after the mar-a-lago raid asa hutchinson
who's the squish
republican governor in arkansas he says
look
fbi was just doing its job
the american public is operating without
sufficient information i think we all
have to take a deep breath and say we're
going to have to wait to see the facts
that come out there is some urgency in
it because
this is unprecedented the search of a
former president's home
the american public wants to understand
that and right now you mentioned the
circling of the of the wagons uh
around uh donald trump and it's simply
because uh they see the establishment as
going after donald trump and
and they question whether that was the
right move and whether it's less
intrusive means to accomplish the same
purpose
we're going to have to be a little
patient
attorney general did the right thing by
getting information out this week well
the gop is going to be the party of
supporting law enforcement law
enforcement includes the fbi the fbi is
simply carrying out their
responsibilities under the law a lawful
search warrant
that a magistrate signed off on
and they didn't go in there with fbi
raid jackets uh they tried to constrain
uh their behavior carrying out that
warrant they're re i really think that
the republicans ought to thank that the
regime's secret police for going in and
raiding the home of the chief political
rival to the president the former
president unprecedented we should be
thankful
they didn't even wear their fbi jackets
because they were so ashamed of what
they were doing because they wanted to
hide the fact that the biden
administration was wielding the fbi to
attack the political opponents
we ought to be listen if we're going to
be pro
law and order
we need to support extremely corrupt law
enforcement agencies do we i don't think
that's true what are you talking about
no i
i support the fbi when the fbi is acting
in a just and proper manner i don't
support the fbi when it's corrupt
and there is no question that the fbi
has exhibited extremely corrupt behavior
in recent years
don't forget it wasn't obama it wasn't
the white house it wasn't even just the
doj it was the fbi that made up evidence
to get the the fisa court judge to allow
the fbi to spy on the trump campaign it
was the fbi kevin kleinsmith fbi lawyer
that did that i'm not saying it's the
regular agents on the ground i don't
think that's true i know a handful of
fbi agents who are good patriotic strong
conservative americans but kevin kline
smith he's not that guy's worse than
dirt that guy's a complete rat who's
who's who is
undermining integrity the integrity of
our law enforcement agencies and faith
that we have in the system that guy
doesn't deserve our support are you
kidding me
merrick garland the attorney general
who's just who's just operating as a
complete hatchet man for the biden
administration and wielding jack-booted
thugs to go attack donald trump that's
not that that's not back the blue that's
not the thin blue line that's corruption
we support the police
we don't support crooked cops
right we
the most hardcore defender of the police
the really good policemen themselves
they're going to be the most outspoken
against the crooked cops because the
crooked cops give them a bad name same
goes for the fbi same goes for the doj
this guy don't forget asa hutchinson
this governor of arkansas he's the one
who defended transiting the kids he
refused to sign a bill that said you
can't trans the kids anymore so this guy
is just the the clowniest of of fake
republicans this guy is the court jester
in the kingdom of liberalism par
excellence you don't want to be on his
side you can notice right now some of
the moderate republicans who had been
leading leaning in that direction of let
this play out we've got to just whatever
the fbi and the doj do that's totally
fine they're starting to walk that back
now because they realize they don't want
to be on the same side as h asa
hutchinson tim scott who i like
personally i think he's a very nice guy
he he really stepped in it last week
when he said that we need to let the
situation play out and not rush to
conclusions when the biden
administration's raiding trump's house
and he got a lot of criticism for that
rightly so now what's he doing he's
walking those comments back
sean this is absurd think about it this
has been a wish hunt for six years think
about the steele dossier the russia
collusion two failed impeachment
attempts
and even more i can't imagine how anyone
in our country doesn't look at this with
eyes of suspicion there's no question in
my mind that this is an overreach at
best and frankly asking for a criminal
warrant that gives you a space of time
between august the 5th and august 19th
because they're looking for
national security sensitive information
there's nothing that comes to the
conclusion that you would ever give
someone two weeks to go through that
process this is devastating we're in
unchartered waters it is stunning to our
country and frankly this is something we
have to continue to dig into we got to
win the majority sean so that we can
actually go through the oversight in the
majority of this process
okay that's really well said i couldn't
have said that better myself i really
like that tim scott i'm going to vote
for that tim scott that's great that's a
180 degree turn from what he said on i
forget which liberal news program on
which liberal network it was last week
but that's a 180 degree turn
last week he said well you know we got
to let this play out we don't want to
rush to conclusions and then what's he
do on sean hannity's show on fox news he
rushes to conclusions and he says this
is ridiculous and he's right he's right
the second clip is correct so i'm glad
tim scott gets total credit he made a
mistake he
went went back he corrected himself
now we got to make sure especially when
it comes to republican politicians i'm
not just singling out tim scott that
they're not just saying one thing to the
liberal audience and another thing to
the moderate audience and another thing
to the conservative audience we got to
make sure they're consistent what tim
scott said on that show is absolutely
right he makes a great point he says why
would the magistrate judge
that authorized this raid
give the fbi two weeks to undertake it
this is supposedly i mean now now the
libs have even dropped this kind of
argument but previously they were
insinuating through anonymous sources
trump had the nuclear codes he had this
is urgent sensitive information that's
why they had to raid trump they couldn't
wait for the lawyers to work it out
okay well if it was so urgent why did
why did the judge give him two weeks to
do it
furthermore if it was so urgent
why did the fbi get the warrant on
august 5th
and then they didn't undertake the raid
until august 8th i was on a show on fox
over the weekend with the liberal brian
tyler cohen and he said oh michael you
know come on it was the weekend
it was the weekend hold on you're
telling me that this is urgent national
security sensitive information we could
be on the brink of nuclear war if the
fbi doesn't get these codes but well you
know i got to crack a few ones and and
have a barbecue with the family i'll get
it on monday i don't think so i don't
think so that doesn't really make a lot
of sense to me
people know the fbi looks terrible here
terrible
john ratcliffe who's the former director
of national intelligence under trump
he's suggesting that very possibly
because of how egregious this action was
by the fbi that christopher wray could
be the last fbi director
he said radcliffe says ray already
admitted that the fbi fraudulently
obtained multiple warrants to illegally
spy on trump as a candidate and during
the presidency if yet another fbi
warrant to raid trump's home doesn't
stand up scrutiny ray may be the last
fbi director this seems kind of
hyperbolic but i don't really think it
is the fbi as we know it today as the
fbi
only began in 1935 it's not that old
christopher wray is the eighth fbi
director
okay it's not
it would
it's not as though this institution's
been around since 1776 folks this is a
relatively modern institution before we
had the fbi we had a different version
of the fbi but it was structurally quite
different that that only even began in
1908 so yeah this this could change okay
the only reason that i don't think that
christopher wray will be the last fbi
director is because the republicans are
cowards and they don't want to wield
power
and you're you're even seeing right now
some of the moderates in the republican
party they're saying oh no we can't talk
about ending the fbi we can't talk about
radically restructuring the fbi no
that's crazy that's not well
what's the alternative what's you're
telling me that the alternative is we're
going to let the fbi just make up
evidence and start raiding the homes of
political opponents to go on fishing
expeditions to stop them from running
for president next cycle
you tell that's better that's more law
and order that's that's what serious
people do
rather than radically restructure the
fbi or get rid of it all together
i don't think so it it'd be one thing if
this were a one-off incident
this has been a consistent pattern of
behavior
for seven years now at least
forget about other abuses that the fbi
has undertaken it's not even only
against trump let's not forget
the the fbi contrived a an assassination
attempt kidnapping attempt rather
against gretchen whitmer the michigan
governor the democrat governor of
michigan who now the the uh
when the people were being prosecuted
for this the criminals who were kind of
entrapped and set up a number of them
got off the hook the ones who didn't
confess to the crime got off the hook
because it was such a bungle by the fbi
and so you're telling me we're going to
allow that to continue of course not
i wouldn't if i were in office right now
i think the your only responsible option
is to radically radically restructure
the fbi you've got to fire i'm not even
saying the regular agents on the ground
a lot of whom do a great job but you've
got to struggle you've got to
restructure the political leadership
that is perverting this institution of
law enforcement to only attack one party
to only go after one party on behalf of
the other party because the other party
the democrats constitute the
semi-permanent ruling class in the
united states
many conservatives don't
want to admit
how politics actually works in this
country forget about the liberals
they're the ones wielding the power
even many conservatives the squishy
types they don't want to admit
how politics actually works they want to
pretend
that we still have neutral institutions
and it's all it's just neutral and we
play out in the fair marketplace of
ideas and we it's okay and then some
sometimes we win sometimes they win
and and that's that and yeah i know the
new york times is a little liberal but
you know look we've got to respect them
no we don't no we don't there's no such
thing as neutrality it doesn't exist
lock that one away with unicorns and
bigfoot okay it's not real
we got more evidence of this just over
the weekend when barry weiss who
formerly worked at the new york times
came out on her podcast and told a story
that should be shocking to the squishes
probably not so shocking to
conservatives who know what's up
here's what happened
i was at the new york times and you or
your staff sent in an op-ed
about the bill and why it fell apart
and this is the part i'm not sure if you
know
there was a discussion about the piece
and whether or not we should run it
and one colleague a more senior
colleague
said to a more junior colleague who was
pushing for the peace
do you think the republicans really care
about minority rights
wow and the more junior colleague said i
think tim scott cares about minority
rights and then and here's the pretty
shocking part the more senior colleague
said
let's check with senator schumer before
we run it
wow
and the colleague the younger one
refused because he said because that
colleague said
it wasn't an ethical thing to do
wow
so you can hear the the man who's
responding coincidentally is tim scott
and tim scott had submitted a kind of
police also coincidentally had submitted
a kind of police reform blm type uh bill
but a republican version of it and
uh he submitted an op-ed to the new york
times
and according to barry weiss the new
york times editor said we got to check
this one out with chuck schumer you know
our boss we got to run this one by our
boss the democrat senate majority leader
because we're the gray lady all the news
that's fit to print except not really
the new york times
i think undeniably at this point
is simply an advertising agency for the
democrat party
so much so that they
actually run
editorial questions by the democrat
senate majority leader
now of course the libs denied this deny
deny deny nate hochman over at national
review has sources that are affirming
barry weiss's account i totally believe
of course you believe it
how can people believe in neutrality
the
the false
notion of neutra political neutrality is
what has gotten us into this mess
this is the subject of my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds i think that thesis has proven
more and more correct every single day
the notion of neutrality in the public
square is what gave us drag queen story
hour the conservative quote-unquote
defense of drag queen story hour was
well we need we need politically neutral
spaces
and then what happens five seconds after
we allow drag queen story hour in the
libraries it goes to the elementary
schools five seconds after that the
elementary school administrators are
allowed to transgender the kids without
asking the parents permission without
even notifying the parents
it just that there is no and by the way
if you refuse to do this if you refuse
to ascend to transgenderism
transvestitism drag queens all of that
you will be punished you will be
ostracized from the public square you
can get in trouble at school you get in
trouble at work there is no neutrality
there are only standards and taboos you
can't live politics in a vacuum
there is no totally neutral paper there
is no totally neutral outlet
there's none of that
the only people who might be totally
neutral are the squish republicans who
have nothing but wind blowing in between
their ears okay because they don't
believe anything they don't know
anything they don't have two brain cells
to rub together but everyone else on the
left and the right they
they are not neutral they have opinions
they have premises they have a basic
view of the world
all neutrality is done is is give
cowards an excuse to surrender
even science even we're told politics
okay maybe politics isn't neutral but
science is neutral even science
is not
neutral if you didn't understand that
before if you haven't understood that
after two and a half years of dr fauci
changing the science based on his
personal political preferences at a whim
sometimes multiple times within a couple
of weeks
check out boston children's hospital
which has a
pediatric
transgender department which is offering
pediatric hysterectomies that means
cutting out the wombs of little girls
now they're going even further
the boston children's hospital is not
just talking about cutting out the
sexual organs of teenagers no no they're
claiming that even toddlers know that
they are transgender
a child will often know that they are
transgender from the moment that they
have any ability to express themselves
and parents will often tell us this we
have parents who tell us that their kids
they knew from the minute they were born
practically
and actions like refusing to get a
haircut or
standing to urinate trying to stand to
urinate refusing to stand to urinate
trying on siblings clothing
playing with the quote opposite gender
toys things like that there is more and
more a group of adolescents that we are
seeing that really are coming to the
realization that they might be trans or
gender diverse a little bit later on in
their life so what we're seeing from
them is that they always sort of knew
something was maybe off and didn't have
the understanding to know that they
might be trans or have a different
gender identity than the one they had
been assigned so that is a growing
population that there that we are seeing
and that's being recognized as being
trans and able to be treated
did your kid have any trouble being
potty trained
yeah probably you should chop off his
his genitals yeah did your did your
uh little girl
sometimes play with like basketballs or
maybe gi joe did you ever pick that up
on yeah you should probably pump her
full of cross-sex hormones get around
some testosterone she's transgender
because the parents are always are
telling the doctors this all the time
you see these parents who come in with
children who in many cases can't even
talk
because they're toddlers and toddlers
can't really talk that well
if at all they come in and they say i
know
i've known since the moment my child was
born
that my little boy is really a little
girl how did i know i just knew because
my child
my child said
and i could tell
i could tell that the child was kind of
lilting his voice a little i know he's a
little boy but he's just the god
it just sounded it sounded like he
wanted to be
a girl it has nothing to do with me i'm
not just a psycho who wanted a different
sex child i'm i just don't it's not that
i want attention from all my liberal
friends and i want to feel like a super
special parent no no it's my
18 month old
is really
is really a category of being
that we didn't acknowledge as being
ontologically sound until
about five minutes ago that's got to be
what it is right
uh no i i don't think so
that lady that lady in that video she's
not a politician
she's a scientist
she's at a very prestigious scientific
institution a medical institution called
boston children's hospital
if you still
say well i trust the doctors i trust the
scientists i trust the experts you're
not going to make it i can't help you i
can't help you
this reminds me of drew clavin talks
about this when you read the newspaper
and you see some article about syria and
you say i don't know about syria okay i
guess i believe that you open up next
it's an article about the stock market
you say i don't know anything about the
stock market well okay i guess i believe
that then you open up the next page it's
about the new york yankees and you do
know about the new york yankees and you
say wait a second that article is bs
they don't know what they're talking
about huh they don't know that then you
move on next article it's about
immigration i don't know about
immigration okay makes sense and you
just believe but you know the one thing
you know about
you know that the the experts and the
geniuses and the opinion setters they're
wrong about
and yet you continue to accept their
opinions and all the things that you
don't know about that's what it's like
with the medical establishment
said this on the show multiple times in
the last few months i
am much more inclined today to trust an
african shaman witch doctor
when it comes to medical advice than i
am to trust
a prestigious senior fellow at the nih
more than i am to trust anybody on the
staff at boston children's hospital
you can't you can't possibly trust them
you can't trust their judgment and this
is happening not just with our
scientific institutions you're certainly
seeing with the fbi i can't trust the
fbi i can't trust the doj when they come
out and you hear oh no so and so
he oh he's a by the books kind of guy
you know he's a careerist at the doj
he's always played it straight i just
can't believe that now because i've seen
the corruption i've seen the terrible
judgment that they've exhibited and the
malice and the attacks on their
political opponents so that's gone and
you can lament oh no we've lost faith in
our institutions and inside okay that's
not my fault i'm doing the only rational
thing i can do which is approach these
institutions with such a radical
skepticism that pretty much anything
they say i'm going to believe the
opposite at this point anything dr fauci
says i'm going to believe the opposite
certainly anything that woman says at
boston children's hospital
the woman who says that 18 months olds
are transgender if they have trouble
potty training
whatever she says i have to assume
the opposite is true speaking of kids
health cbs news
is taking on the this this real problem
that we have in our country which is
that
young people are not as physically fit
as they once were they're not going out
they're not playing around they're not
playing sports they're not they're just
getting kind of fatter and softer and
this is a big problem cbs has uncovered
why that is the answer of course
climate change
the new study showing how climate change
specifically higher temperatures is
making our children uh more inactive and
more obese the study published in
journal temperature found today's
children are 30 percent less aerobically
fit than their parents were at their age
fewer children are reaching the world
health organization's recommendation of
60 minutes of exercise a day now listen
it has been a lot harder hotter and the
weather has been crazy but i think it
also has to do with technology you know
yeah it's one thing not to go outside
but these kids don't go outside because
they can stay inside and be on their
phones play video games and be social
without having to go outside and be
social
even the cbs guy cannot do this segment
with a straight face the powers that be
sent them this segment they said you got
to talk about how
kids are fat and unhealthy because of
glo the sun monster that's why and that
guy i don't even know his name he's on
cbs he's like
he's like okay i read all the stuff that
i'm supposed to read about the sun
monster but
it's just video games and ipads right
hold on you're telling me
that because of the
allegedly .001
degree fahrenheit that it's hotter today
than it was some time ago that's why
kids are all way fatter and less healthy
it has nothing to do with all the
extremely processed poisonous food
they're eating has nothing to do with
all the drugs that their parents are
putting them on has nothing to do with
the ipads and the video games and the
tvs that they're all glued to 24 7. just
doom-scrolling through life no it has
nothing to do with that it's because of
global warming are you and so the guy he
says man come on this is my
you can't this is too much even for me
and i work for cbs news
but still but still
as ridicu as
patently absurd as this story is
the people who set the editorial agenda
at the new york at cbs it's probably
chuck schumer too
these guys are still going to at least
present this propaganda they're going to
get it out there you'll notice something
if you if you've been following
meteorological charts you know the
weatherman on news you'll notice that
they've changed the colors in recent
years
it's pretty jarring but for the very
same temperatures
that you've seen
10 years ago even 20 years ago heat
waves happen it's the summer okay heat
waves happen in hot places especially
you'll see instead of in the old days it
would be yellow would be the color or
green now it's always red it's bright
red because it's a climate emergency
because whenever when it's hot in the
summer that's evidence that you need to
stop eating meat and stop driving your
car and stay in the pod and
eat bugs and don't go anywhere and you
don't
meanwhile of course john kerry and
prince harry and all the rest and
leonardo dicaprio they're going to fly
around on their private jets and sail on
their yachts but you look the color's
red kids are getting fat and unhealthy
because you're eating meat so you gotta
stop global warming's
global warming and even this guy he says
guys come on can't you be a little more
subtle
than this
no kids are fat because of ipads and
drugs and crappy food they're not
fat because of the sun monster good
grief
regardless though of why it is americans
are not exactly in fighting form
especially young
americans
there is a man who has been around
foreign policy and statecraft for i
think 700 years at this point henry
kissinger henry kissinger was the
secretary of state for richard nixon
he's now i believe 99 years old he's got
his 18th or 19th book out
and the book is worth paying attention
to because i don't i don't agree with
henry kissinger on everything but he's
he's really good on on
real politik you know he's he's really
good on taking the kind of idealism and
platitudes out of foreign policy and
just talking in terms of cold hard
interests and henry kissinger believes
that we are on the brink of war in the
united states and the really bad news
here
beyond the fact that our young people
are not not in fighting form and i don't
think that america right now with
one of the worst economies we've ever
had in our nation's history and with
people who are not exactly patriotic and
with people who are physically not very
fit
the other problem is henry kissinger
believes we're on the brink of war not
just with one power but with two
kissinger believes that we are on the
brink of war with russia
and china and furthermore he agrees with
me that a lot of it is our fault not our
fault but the fault of our stupid
leaders
are you still giving your money to woke
razor companies that hate your values
that see masculinity as toxic and think
you should teach your daughter to shave
her beard
there is a better way jeremy's razors
100 real 100 woke free the premium matte
tungsten handle has more heft than the
left
the razor head pivots without caving and
has six blades that are sharper than
truth
when you buy jeremy's razors you aren't
just making jeremy richer you're making
the woke left poorer 75 000 people have
already made the switch visit
ihateharrys.com
to get your founders series shave kit
today that is i hate harry's dot com
jeremy's razors shut up and shave
henry kissinger says we're on the brink
of war because our stupid leaders have
made a lot of bad decisions
i have been saying this for months now
and i have been smeared as a pro-putin
puppet and all sorts of dumb
left-wing slogans because of it but
henry kissinger says that i'm right
kissinger makes this point he says quote
americans resist separating the idea of
diplomacy from that of personal
relationships with the adversary they
tend to view negotiations he tells me in
missionary rather than psychological
terms seeking to convert or condemn
their interlocutors rather than to
penetrate their thinking
from the beginning of the war in ukraine
the approach that i've had to it is from
the perspective of what does putin want
why is he doing this what does he want
why does he think this benefits him
right now to do this
the libs and the squishes
have approached it from putin bad he's
the most bad man the baddest most bad
man ever and zielinski he's a good man
very much the good man and not bad man
you say okay maybe maybe all of that's
true i don't know but it's not going to
help you understand anything about the
war in ukraine it's not going to help
you understand how we got here certainly
not going to help you understand how we
get out
kissinger says we're at the edge of war
with russia and china on issues which we
partly created without any concept of
how this is going to end or what it's
supposed to lead to i said from the
beginning i said nato bears a lot of
responsibility here for creating a
provocative situation nato doesn't bear
moral responsibility for invading
ukraine obviously
depending on how you think of the maidan
revolution in 2014 but it's not as
though tanks are rolling in from the
west into ukraine that's not what they
bear responsibility for but they bear
nato and the united states leading it
bears some responsibility
for
misplaying
our hands that's what i said when i said
that what did i you're a pro
russia stooge puppet kisses you're
saying the same thing
he says we're at the brink of war
because of issues that we've partly
created
kissinger said that in cautious policies
on the part of the us and nato may have
touched off the crisis in ukraine
he sees no choice but to take vladimir
putin's stated security concerns
seriously and believes that it was a
mistake for nato to signal to ukraine
that it might eventually join the nato
alliance he said
i won't do a henry kissinger because you
want people to understand a word i say
said i thought that poland all the
traditional western countries that had
been part of western history were
logical members of nado
but ukraine and his view is a collection
of territories once appended to russia
which russians see as their own even
though some ukrainians do not stability
would be better served by its acting as
a buffer between russia and the west
he says i was in favor of the full
independence of ukraine but i thought
its best role was something like finland
this is exactly my perspective
on
russia and ukraine
border states
are good but rather buffer states are
good states between great powers and
rival powers it's good to have a little
buffer in between them that plays each
side off of the other one
doesn't make you a putin stooge doesn't
make you a tear anti-american or
anything like that the people who were
urging caution on nato expansion after
the fall of the berlin wall were george
kenned daniel patrick moynihan sam young
really mainstream people
somewhat liberal people actually and
they were cold warriors who were really
tough on the soviet union in the cold
war but they realized that our foreign
policy has been really really stupid
and you're seeing this right now even
with the fbi even on the domestic front
you are seeing
bad political actors let their emotions
get away with them and destroy
hard one peace
and hard-won stability in our country
because they want to get trump they hate
trump so much
and we've got it we've got to get putin
and we've got to antagonize putin and
we've got to go this guy and get the
other guy and they're not thinking
strategically they're not thinking from
the perspective of what is best for
americans
before we go there's a little a little
glimmer of hope here that i want to get
to that might improve
our state in in this country and in the
world
a major democrat congressman carolyn
maloney
said thinking she was speaking off the
record that she was not that joe biden
is not running again
carolyn maloney when asked should
president biden run again also by the
new york times she said off the record
he's not running again and then the
times responded not off the record on
the right you're on the record right now
you're not off the record and she goes
on the record no he should not run again
he should not run hold on wait i thought
you just said off the record he is not
running again so biden is going to say
that he's running because he has to say
that he's running because he doesn't
want to be a lame duck
but you've now got really top in the
know
democrat elected officials saying
he's not running again which means that
as you are seeing all sorts of
shenanigans play out uh from the left to
the right to try to take out donald
trump as a presidential candidate
you are about to see
a shivving
the likes of which
has not been seen in quite a while
between kamala harris pete buddha judge
gavin newsom and whichever other
democrats
are going to try to throw their hat in
the ring before we go also a line from
al gore speaking of presidential
wannabes
al gore for some reason people still ask
his opinion al gore goes on
a news show
and al gore
uh
says
that the fbi and the uh attorney general
merrick garland acted entirely
appropriately
what is your reaction to all we've
learned does this make sense to you why
a former president would have such
documents in his
florida mansion
uh no no it doesn't but i want to hasten
to add i don't know the facts i'll tell
you what i do know i know merrick
garland and i don't know that our nation
has ever had
an attorney general who is more
committed to doing things according to
the book according to the proper order
uh
it's unthinkable that he would take any
kind of rash step or violate the regular
order i have tremendous confidence in
him his probity and everyone who knows
him and has worked with him feels the
same way so i'm sure the justice
department and the fbi have been have
acted entirely properly
i'm sure i mean why would anyone doubt
that they it's not as though they've
been caught
violating the law when it comes to trump
for seven years of course of course and
it's so funny coming from this guy's
mouth because all we talk about a
resisting the peaceful transfer of power
we talk about how trump undermined our
democratic institutions and undermined
an election
this freaking guy refused to concede the
2000 presidential election after he lost
he brought this thing all the way up to
the supreme court of the united states
totally needlessly because he couldn't
take the fact that he lost the election
made us a
global laughing stock the united states
greatest democracy in the world can't
conduct its own elections i'm so glad al
gore is getting his voice back out here
because it's a reminder to you that all
the things the libs accuse us of doing
they themselves have committed
up to and including and most especially
not accepting the results of elections
whatever
they say about trump no matter how much
they move the goal posts they'll
probably change the justification for
the raid five different times today
don't believe it it's just totally fake
they have no credibility at all
and
most important of all most important
take this lesson to the bank do not be a
squish do not be like asa hutchinson do
not be like any of these toadies these
court jester conservatives who are on
the same side as that guy
we're on the same side as the new york
times we're on the same side as boston
children's hospital transiting the kids
that's not the side you want to be on
and there's no neutrality either folks
the rest
of the show
is going to continue now what do you
mean the rest of the show i thought this
was the end of the show no
we've got more show coming we've got a
new feature here from the daily wire
it's the member block it's not for you
hoy poloy okay it's not for you filthy
unwashed masses out there who refuse to
sign up and become a daily wire member
no no
this is for the daily wire members over
at dailywire.com uh there's one more
story i have got to get to this actually
kind of wanted to get to it in the main
show today but all right we'll get to it
in in the member block this the atlantic
is now claiming that rosaries you know
like a rosary beads like christians pray
that that is now
an extremist symbol so i want to get to
that story i also want to get uh to a
real-time music video reaction to
compliance by muse i do some of these
kind of things over on my youtube
channel sometimes now we've got a lot
more in the member block if you're not a
member click the link in the description
to join us all right that's our show i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you